hello folks
welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany and
today we have a busy day because the
other day
i failed to answer questions i left them
for today so they piled up on me
okay so i'll be doing that at the end of
the
lecture today and so why don't we get
started with
extinction topic which is very
interesting for us here
and for a lot of people obviously lots
of questions so
i'll uh have it be driven by
questions and comments okay here's the
first one okay
uh fellow says he says uh referring to
me he says he used to say that
we are the last generation of humans now
he says
i'm only talking about mechanisms
no dates no no uh let's make sure we
understand i never gave a date
i i i've never given a date saying you
know like the
1st of may of the year 2028 we're going
to all go extinct
never gave a date we're not astrologers
okay
we're scientists okay scientist what
does he do he explains
mechanisms okay so uh
and physics is only about explaining
mechanisms okay
so that's what we do here what's the
theory in general terms
if food disappears man will die
no matter what now a lot of people have
uh
trouble understanding that they they
don't think that's true that
if um if we don't have any food
we live forever i guess we breathe air
or something i don't know
uh yeah if food disappears on the planet
uh we're all dead okay that's that's the
bottom line on that theory
where do we get that we say that's what
happened to the animals in the past that
died in a mass extinction food will
disappear when okay no one produces it
okay so no one produces food we all sit
right and just
uh fold our arms right
uh if no one produces food or
distributes it for that matter or
whatever is
left um for sure you know you're gonna
die of starvation
okay so hopefully the only reason you
live today is because someone
is producing food and someone is
delivering it okay i don't know
what problem you could have with that
but some people do have problems with
that
and then the final part i guess you
could say is no one will produce food or
distribute it right
when money is no more
okay so when money is no more okay
no one will produce or distribute food
that's in general terms the theory now
what part of that
you think has to do with astrology i
don't know
it has to do with an explanation of a
mechanism here we're explaining the
mechanism
that leads to the demise of our species
uh that's it that's all we can say about
that
okay um another fellow raises an issue i
don't know if you've already read it but
i suggest gary allen's book
none dare call it conspiracy lots of
people doing conspiracies these days
especially on the internet
widespread okay and all i can tell you
is the following as
far as gary allen's book okay the
illuminati will not
corral humans in chicken coops or
enslave them when money is no more
why because they're well first of all
there won't be any new world order
okay and there will be the extinction of
man
instead why because without money or
trade
the filthy rich have no means to compel
to compel you to do anything they can't
compel the cops to do
anything they can compare compel the
military
they cannot compel a single human to do
something because they have no way of
influencing them because there is no
money there is no trade
okay that's the bottom line that's
that's what the theory says whether you
believe it or not it's a separate matter
right now we're just talking about um
mechanisms okay okay uh
next issue here next comment
says the question you always have to ask
yourself is who is being
paying bill gatey today to tell you that
you
to tell youtube the sky is falling is it
china
iran uh
you know what's funny is that here we
have another fellow and
uh he says uh something different he
says you say that
snowden assange cia operatives because
they are
running free does that mean you are also
a current cia operative on a mission to
reduce the world population
well these guys should get together and
you know figure it out i mean
uh one guy says it's china iran it's
paying me the other guy is saying that's
the cia
maybe the nsa or who knows you know uh
you guys fight it out amongst yourself
figure out who's paying me okay
anyways meanwhile i can only tell you
here um
that regarding that last comment to
reduce the
world population the global population
growth rate is coming down without my
help believe me
i'm not helping it come down i'm not
scaring anyone not to have kids
we're not having kids because everybody
has moved to the cities
you can't have children in the cities
that's the bottom line it's known as
density dependent birth rates okay
and i've covered that subject lightly in
the past
uh one day i'll probably cover it in
more depth okay and now
regarding uh you know
misinformation you know the cia
disseminates conspiracy
theories to undermine conspiracy
theorists okay so keep that in mind it's
in to the advantage of the intelligence
agencies to have lots of conspiracies
out there
why because you know um it confuses
people
people say well this guy says that jfk
was done by lee harvey oswald the other
guy says it was done by the mafia this
other guy says it was the cia you know
and so the more
theories are out there what it does is
people roll their eyes and say oh my god
another conspiracy theory
and so it debases all the conspiracy
theories
so the only people who benefit
from conspiracy theories from from many
of them
are the intelligence agencies they love
conspiracy theories okay in fact they
they probably uh throw in some
themselves they disperse some on their
own you know
uh you know their own uh
interests farfet's
theories are sprinkled to get people to
what to roll their eyes
and you have to choose your conspiracy
conspiracy theories
well okay uh not all conspiracy theo
not all conspiracists okay believe in
the same things
okay and that's another thing that you
know uh
helps people in their arguments against
conspiracy theories
they say oh you're a conspiracist
meaning that you're a flat earther
no no no i'm talking about this other
thing no no they put you on the same
boat as flat earthers so
everybody who has a conspiracy theory of
some kind they're put in the same boat
with everybody else with all the
conspiracy theories and they say oh
you're a conspiracist
okay so you got a label uh so
what i do and uh here you heard it okay
for the first time
i'm gonna give you my conspiracy
theories
my list of them so that you don't
misquote me these are the ones
i've researched and these are the ones i
vouch for
okay uh anything that's not on this list
is not you know you can't blame me for
it okay so here it goes
just so uh you know where i come from
these are my favorite conspiracy
theories secretary of war edwin stanton
he was the intellectual
author behind lincoln assassination
stalwart roscoe conklin he was the
intellectual author of the garfield
assassination the main sinking u.s flag
what to conquer some of the spanish
empires uh colonies out there
spanish empire was crumbling so that's
what they did
mckinley assassination an artist leon
chalgash
he acted alone he's just uh he was a
lone gunman
one of the few uh titanic white star
line substituted the olympic to collect
insurance okay roosevelt attempt
john shrank again lone gunman i don't
think uh anything
there was a any conspiracy there at all
they tried to kill him he carried the
bullet for the rest
of his life in his chest lucitania
uh wilson false flag his administration
they needed to
re-elect them so he ran with a ticket
saying uh
he kept us out of the war and the first
thing he does is get into the war and
the lusitania was uh in the back of
people's mind
okay uh florence kling
uh she was the intellectual author of
the harding assassination not not uh
he didn't die of natural cause he was
murdered okay pearl harbor u.s flag to
uh false flag to enter world war ii okay
not that they said hey jabs come over
here and
and attack pearl harbor but they knew
japan was going to attack and they said
go ahead you know
knock the chip off my shoulder okay and
then uh here's another
group of false flags that uh
more more recent i guess you could say
uh hoover
he liquidated marilyn monroe uh johnson
and hoover did jfk
johnson hoover did oswald and a whole
bunch of other people you know
related to jfk assassination they had to
get rid of a lot of
people who knew too much okay gulf of
tonkin
johnson's false flag you know that's
essentially
known today okay not too many people
have doubts about that okay hoover did
malcolm x as well
in 1968 man did go to the moon
so that conspiracy that the nasa
uh is doing all this work and stuff so
that people don't find out about
man going to the moon or the space
program
nonsense man did go to the moon man has
gone into space
we do send uh rovers to mars you know
and not only the united states but
russia and china you know and other
countries japan
okay uh reagan attempt lone gunman john
hinckley
no conspiracy there i think he acted
alone 9 11 bush team false flag
quite evident no i don't think there's
much question in the minds of a rational
person
that uh the bush team did 9 11.
cheney he liquidated senator wilson and
his family
got the plane down okay
uh wilson was from what is it minnesota
and uh flat earthers possible false flag
i can't tell you for sure
uh it's kind of strange that uh you know
these people grew so fast
uh so quickly uh in in uh
a relatively short time uh possibly
just a snowball that just kept
collecting people
it could be run by intelligence agencies
and both assange and
snowden those are obviously false flags
in my opinion
okay i have no problem with looking at
those two individuals and saying
they are usa assets intelligence assets
okay uh one file says
depression script money disappeared
during the depression
so people created local money called
depression script
okay so you're wrong when money
disappears new money
appears uh
no new money won't appear because
trade will be no more because you only
trade but
what he's referring to essentially is
bartering okay
the fact that you use a currency or that
you exchange goods
or good for service it doesn't really
matter
the point is people won't trade and uh
a great measure because they won't trust
each other once the only thing of value
is food okay nobody trades food
whether in the real jungle out there in
forests or in the asphalt jungle
okay likewise when man disappears a new
man will appear
i don't know what kind of man will well
up here
with uh you know antennas or something
no the economy is not built on faith it
is built on
confidence i like that one
by the way those are some of the uh
depression script
bills that they use in those days uh why
do i laugh at what he said because
it turns out when you look it up
confidence is a synonym of faith
faith of confidence okay so it's not
built on confidence it's built on
confidence that's all he said
okay the depression script was used
during the depression era in the 30s
right as a substitute for
government issued currency because the
bank's closing temporarily and a lack of
physical currency someone had to come up
with another form of currency
to keep the money the economy going and
a way for trade to continue
yeah that's when you have the global
economy is still running fine
okay so that's what we're missing here
the context
the context is that there's still an
economy out there
uh so you create a money because you
know you you're gonna get something in
the future
okay so that's why you accept that money
okay
therefore the old idea of local currency
was reborn paper
cardboard wood and all other stuff that
they use
uh made from fishken was used
uses money yeah again uh this isn't
not an issue of uh whether you can
create some
money and decide to trade with your
neighbor that's not the issue
the issue here is that you won't trade
with your neighbor okay but yeah you can
use anything for money you can even use
you know trade your wife
for his dog if you want i mean it
doesn't really matter
trade only as long as trade exists when
trade is no more then
there is there's no reason to trade
because there's nothing to trade because
you won't get anything out of it and the
only thing of value
at that point is food food is the only
thing of value
and here let me show you an example okay
because people have a hard time
understanding that
trade disappears okay so here we'll give
an extreme example so that you
understand
why trade is not always
in the best interest of the parties okay
here he goes okay you're just your ship
capsized
okay and two fellows you know they make
it to a little island there on
onshore one guy brings a treasure chest
he's got all this money's hey before the
ship sinks
i'm gonna make sure i get all the money
i can out of there and he goes and
brings in the treasure chest
the other guy brings uh you know food he
brings apples
uh potatoes whatever you can find in the
kitchen i guess right
or in stock room in the stock room and
it turns out he
ends up in the uh palm tree
side of the island fine great anyways uh
the first thing they both do is protect
themselves putting barbed wire and
building trenches why
because you know one guy's afraid the
other guy will steal his stuff steal his
stuff right
but it turns out that one guy has an
advantage over the other and that is
that
he's got the food he's got the thing
that's going to keep him alive
the other guy's just hoping to go back
to civilization and use the treasure
chest
well it turns out that you know it all
depends on luck if another ship comes
around yeah the guy with uh with the
treasure chest might be in
in very good luck on the other hand
uh you know if no one shows up for a
while
that guy's in trouble because he's got a
lot of money and he has no use for it on
that island
okay it's the guy who's got the food
that's got an advantage
and he can get the treasure chest once
the other guy's dead
now i don't know if you understood any
of that some people have trouble
understanding all this stuff but
yeah trade is not always in the best
interest of the parties
uh and not necessarily always voluntary
um so here um let me give you another
little story okay this is not mine it's
uh
some of you might know it says sanji's
backstory one piece
you can look it up on youtube little
video cartoon video
just made by the japanese and uh
and um i'll just briefly tell you the
story it's that
a pirate and a kid end up on an island
just pretty much like these other two
guys you know this
island's completely empty there's
nothing there
and they managed to get some stuff off
the ship
okay that sank okay so the guy the
pirate gives the kid a bag a small
bag of food okay and he says go to the
other side of the island
and you look in that direction and find
out if there's a ship there coming and
let me know as soon as possible as soon
as you see a ship
that's coming to rescue us and i'm gonna
do it on this side
and he keeps a big bag okay
okay so the kid goes to the other side
and he watches watches and he's eating
his food
right until it finally dwindles to
nothing
and he remembers that the uh pirate the
old pirate he kept a big bag
he said ah that sob he's got all that
food here i'm starving
and so he goes he goes to where the
pirate is
and the pirate says what did you uh
did you see a ship coming is that why
you came over he says
no i came because you gave me a small
bag of food and look at the big bag you
have so he takes his knife and
rips the bag open and it's not food
what comes out is all the gold coins the
balloons
the treasure chest was in his bag he
gave the kid the food
and he kept all the money pretty much
like i explained a second ago
and uh well you can look at the moral of
the story over there okay
anyways yeah it's not always a good deal
to uh
get treasure money uh bitcoins
uh ethereum or whatever
no no uh towards the end of uh when the
global economy collapses
the only thing of value will be food
you'd be a
fool if you go out there and say oh i'm
gonna rob the bank
now that the bank's uh free of people
and there's no police i'm going to rob
the bank and take all the money out
yeah well good good luck with all that
you know
you won't be able to use it for anything
you'll be stuck on that same island
okay another fellow raises another issue
says
what about genetic modification of
crops to keep producing food that is
resistant to changes in climate and so
on
isn't that kind of science the only
thing that can extend the human overall
longevity on this planet
this is not about climate change believe
me not at least not the theory we
we espouse here you know this is not
about climate change
what is it about it's about the economy
collapsing
and no one's gonna be producing
genetically modified
anything because uh you gotta pay these
guys to do that genetically stuff
uh modified stuff and the issue is that
no one will be planting no one will be
harvesting meaning that no one will be
packaging and no one will be
distributing food in any way shape or
form
because the economy has collapsed
what i mean by economic collapse i don't
mean a
petty 1929 depression or even a
recession
i mean a total collapse of the global
economy
no trade no more trade money is no more
because people will not accept it
because they will not be able to do
anything with the money they get
whether it's bitcoin whether it's uh
fiat money whatever it is it doesn't
matter
okay and bartering nobody barters food
which is the only thing of value when
the economy collapses
you don't trade your car
[Music]
or you don't trade your food for a car
okay you let the guy keep the car you
keep the food
when he dies you take the car for free
if there's still any gasoline around
okay if anyone manufactures that and
distributes it so uh
yeah um no
no no purpose for uh genetically
modified foods
it doesn't help us at all
okay just uh i want to mention uh again
related to the subject i touched the
other day which is genetic diversity
okay
and what do we have we have the african
elephants came out uh
i think yesterday or today african
elephants now listed
as critically endangered after dramatic
population decline
uh yeah so uh the african elephants are
disappearing
okay and partly um
because of what i explained the other
day the shrinking island theory
that you know the world is uh shrinking
they have uh less acreage
in which to you know uh scrounge around
for food
and so uh yeah and and the reason for
that is humans are encroaching on their
habitat
humans are turning a lot of that land
into
crops into cropland that is used for
food for humans and the elephants are
are being cornered they're being uh
corralled into an
island that is shrinking on them day by
day
okay what does that do well uh part of
the process
is the loss of genetic diversity and
here you have a little article i'm just
putting a summary here of what this
article says and there were a couple
studies more than one study it says
uh africa as two elephant species
genetic analysis confirms well one of
those at least uh
it has very little genetic diversity
meaning that uh you know the elephants
especially those
i think it's uh was a savannah elephant
that was
declining in genetic diversity or has
very low genetic diversity
they've been around for a while and not
only do we have the problem where
you know the world is collapsing on them
the their islands are shrinking
but on top of that they're you know
they're intermeering uh within the uh
within whatever elephants are out there
and so they have a genetic
problem as well and it's typical you
have a double whammy you know you have a
genetic
loss of genetic diversity and you have
the overturning of the population
pyramid
which is an issue related to density
dependence
why because their islands are shrinking
so you can't continue expanding and
having more and more and more elephants
and their sources of food are declining
declining and declining
and i showed the other day the uh what
is it the
bacteria or the fungus on fruits and
veggies at first they grow exponentially
but after you know their world collapses
on themselves under their feet well
their world starts dropping until they
finally become extinct when there is no
more food left
their world collapses totally okay all i
can ask
is that people who like the issue of
extinction who want to
debate or talk about it or put comments
or questions
follow extinction 101 before you do
follow before you do extinction 102.
extinction 101 mass extinctions of the
past
both animals and plants see if you can
answer how
animals in the plant animals and plants
in the past
died disappeared if you have a foolproof
mechanism okay hopefully you don't have
any catastrophic theories
because the problem is you cannot
explain selectivity
and then once you have your theory your
foolproof theory
well then you can say okay that's going
to happen to man as well because
we cannot avoid that same mechanism okay
that's that's the uh that's the
reasoning behind this
and so yes i do have a theory i'm saying
that the animals in the past died
when their food sources disappeared
gradually at first and then
exponentially towards the end and they
finally went away because their islands
collapsed on them
now it doesn't mean that all their food
completely disappeared but the forests
were getting smaller and smaller and
smaller
that means we have a density dependent
issue means you have the overturning of
the population pyramid of different
species of animals in fact of the whole
order and
take for example the dinosaurs the most
popular one
and at some point it disappeared they
disappear because uh
you know you just have intermarriage you
have fewer and fewer of these peop of
these
animals and their islands are getting
smaller you get the whole whammy all
together
including diversity population pyramid
overturn etc
that's the general idea why is that
important well because that's what's
going to happen to man
okay what's going to happen our food
sources
are going to disappear why are they
going to disappear because we're not
we're producing the food for humans okay
and we won't produce food for humans
anymore because the economy collapsed
the global economy collapsed
a lot of people say well i'll produce my
own food people who have land out there
and they say i'll produce my own food
the big problem there is going to be
defense okay you're going to have to
defend
what you grow out there and good luck
with that when thousands of people from
the country come and visit you to share
in your bounty
okay so the mechanism is the
disappearance of food okay
that's the mechanism for both past mass
extinctions
as well as the one that i propose for
humans
okay let's move on to the lecture today
and it's got to do with uh
this i'll call it a thing for now
it's called a tesseract or a hypercube
yeah and maybe a lot of you have heard
about it okay
uh it comes from really from relativity
okay because it's um
identified or associated
with space-time which is also a
four-dimensional
again for a lack of a better word i'll
say thing
for a dimensional thing called
space-time within which we
live we live within this box known as
space-time okay
and so yeah these notions are concepts
are
related okay so let's see uh what i'm
going to do is i'll drive it through
uh again comments that people made
specifically one individual who
wrote quite a bit and i think each point
was well taken in other words needs to
be addressed
okay so here it goes we'll put this man
in um
in the spotlight okay here it goes okay
uh this gentleman says a sphere is an
object
we start with sphere okay because we
need to find out you know what the
how the reasoning goes okay says a
sphere is an object
we can see and touch okay that's why he
thinks it's an object because you can
see it
and touch it and that's what most people
out there think
an object is that which you can see and
touch
you know this is the ordinary notion
that most people have out there if you
ask anyone on the street that's probably
what they'll tell you
what does it not do well it's what i can
see and touch you know i can see and
touch the table so that's an object
that's the notion people have out there
and in fact that is the
definition we find in uh the dictionary
the ordinary dictionary
and uh it turns out it's also a synonym
of the word exist
because when you ask someone well what
do you mean by exists that
this table exists you say well i can see
and touch it
so the word exists in the word object or
thing
entity medium whatever you want to call
it all these synonyms
uh they're synonyms exist and object are
synonyms in the minds of all people out
there
okay and we try to correct that we have
a different definition
and he says okay it is three-dimensional
okay
true a sphere is three-dimensional and
he says it can be weighed or
measured weight or measured
a sphere is an ideal
geometric object should be at least
that's what we think it is that's what
the word
sphere has always more or less been
alluded to
okay and so you know when you look at a
sphere
you look at something that looks like a
ball you know something like like that
similar to that but it's a perfect
perfectly smooth
geometric object in other words it's an
ideal geometric object because we cannot
produce
anywhere in the universe a perfect
sphere
you know if you go in there with your
you know with god's eyes
and you look at it with uh your
magnifying glass
you'll see some you'll see some
imperfections so there is no such thing
as a
perfect sphere out there in the universe
therefore you cannot weigh it
you cannot touch and you cannot measure
it because there is no such
it out there okay so no
a sphere cannot be touched or uh
seen or weighed but see um we got
another
issue here and that's uh this
okay uh that according to mathematical
physics which is
what i've discussed last time a sphere
is a what is it it's the twirling
of a uh albeit itinerary
you do an itinerary which is known as a
circle
which is just a bunch of locations okay
you cut that
itinerary in half you know that circular
itinerary you cut it in half and you
have what is known as a semi-circle
and then what you're going to do you're
going to twirl that semicircle which is
just a bunch of locations
and that's known as a sphere according
to all those sources that you see there
now discussed that last week so you can
check on that okay
so no a sphere is not an object
according to
mathematical physics according to formal
geometry
no a sphere is what you're seeing there
just a twirling of
a uh of a bunch of locations in other
words of an itinerary okay
in fact half half a circle which is i
said what is a circle a bunch of
locations
okay now here's the other issue and that
is can this individual
see or touch the sphere that the klingon
has
who lives gazillions of light years away
can you see or touch that sphere
hopefully the answer is no
unless you're a superhuman and you know
i do envy your eyesight if you can
see it and i in envy your
lung arm of the law that you can stretch
your hand all the way to that sphere
and touch it so if you can't see or
touch the klingons
sphere is that sphere a physical object
i mean you know for him it is but is it
for you
and so we get into this thing where you
know it comes down to opinions
and uh you know it's like um it depends
on uh
subjectivity you know is is that's
is is his sphere an object for you
does that sphere exist if exists is
re it is uh defined as c and touch
okay so this is the issue and so this is
the question
this gentleman has to answer okay
uh here's another uh issue in what this
gentleman
raised let me see if i can put this back
up here
i can find it i think it's this one yeah
uh this is a second issue okay here it
goes
and it's the word surface that he's got
in that second mind says
its surface is two dimensional well what
i see there is that it's
the surface is three-dimensional you
know i see that
uh the entire surface you know even but
what is the surface you know
surface is the ball without its center
okay without anything in the center it's
just the the skin of the ball so to
speak
and that skin is three-dimensional it's
got length width and height so i don't
know what he means by
that the surface of that sphere is
two-dimensional
so that's something he's got to clarify
now in science it's uh that's a
three-dimensional
skin or or membrane or whatever
and here you look up the word surface
this is out of the wikipedia it says the
outer face
outside or exterior boundary of a thing
outermost or uppermost layer or
area uh the problem is that they use uh
these
synonyms known as space and area and
when you look them up uh
you know they're just synonyms of the
word surface so we don't know what they
said when they said it's the
face the outside uh area or whatever
and then you have um exterior boundary
you look at boundary as
the farthest limit of an area border
and if you use the boundary of a
three-dimensional object such as a
sphere versus a two-dimensional
plane like a circle well uh
those boundaries are not the same
they're not the same notions
okay so the word boundary needs to be
defined as well
a little more precisely so that we know
what they mean by surface
and of course uh what this shows is that
mathematical physics
never defined words scientifically never
there's not a single definition which is
scientific in all of mathematical
physics
and here's a another definition of
surface this comes from
the i think it's the wikipedia yeah
again
and it's got the set of uh definitions
so let's go
quickly through them says surface area
of a solid
object is a measure of the total area
that the surface of the object
occupies okay we're talking about volume
here
i don't know is is that what the surface
area is
the amount of water uh the rubber ducky
displaces
says this definition of surface area is
based on methods
of infinitesimal calculus and involves
partial derivatives
and double integration what does
mathematics have to do with a question
before us
we're trying to figure out what a
surface area is
from physics a physics point of view
we're not trying to calculate anything
we're trying to find out what the
definition of surface
area is specifically we want to know
what a surface is
okay so we look up surface and with a
surface a two-dimensional manifold
what is a manifold okay we look that up
it's a topological space that locally
resembles
euclidean space near each point
okay so what is a topological space what
is a set of points
and what is a euclidean space well it
says consists of points
so uh what is a surface well apparently
it's a bunch of points
i mean that's what all this amounts to
it's just a bunch of points
what is the point according to euclid
well we covered that in the past
and it's a point as a location so a
a surface is a bunch of locations so why
don't
we make the effort and define this
scientifically what is a surface in
science in physics
so here it goes okay pay attention
here's the definition
of a surface for the purposes of physics
slash science okay
that's it folks it's very simple we
don't need math we don't need all this
gibberish there
three or more locations on an object
okay
if you have three locations on a sphere
you have a surface if you have three
locations
on a plane ideal plane for example
again you have a surface typically in
physics
which deals only with objects that exist
a surface is equal to
the location of three atoms okay so
we're talking about the locations
of three atoms that comprise the object
under study see how simple it was three
locations
that's it that's what a surface is
okay uh now that we have a definition
maybe we can uh make sense of
some things here okay here's a swallow
it says
says um a high first feeder
has a three-dimensional surface okay
which curves into fourth dimensional
location
fourth dimensional location what is a
fourth dimensional
location what the hell is that i thought
location was
a concept and this person is talking
about like
that location has four dimensions i mean
i don't know
exactly what he means he's got to
clarify what a fourth dimensional
location is
as far as i'm concerned location doesn't
have any
dimensions whatsoever you can locate
an object using three coordinates
that's that's how it's done in science
it came in physics
and it says hypersphere is the four
dimensional analog
of a sphere whatever that might mean
okay no no here's in science okay you
have uh sphere has length width and
height
three dimension very straightforward
there is no fourth dimension that we're
aware of but
people are welcome
to propose uh you know first to draw
another 90-degree line to those three
there to show us that there
is a fourth dimension and give it a name
we need to find out what the name of
that dimension is
okay and then that's got nothing to do
with the location of the sphere
somewhere in the universe okay and for
that we use uh these
they're known as coordinates and they're
known as longitude latitude
and altitude and uh they differ from
dimensions in that they point towards
the object okay so
uh coordinates point towards an object
and whereas dimensions point away
it's facing you know what direction uh
the the thing in question is facing or
pointing
to okay so dimensions always point
outwards
and coordinates always point inwards
both are static concepts
and they have nothing to do with numbers
whatsoever that's in physics okay we're
talking about physics here okay we don't
talk
about math for example and what do we do
in science well we have to define what
the word location means and here's the
definition okay we start with the word
object first word we have to define in
physics is the word object
you can't do physics without objects
what is an object that which has shape
not that which you can touch not that
which you can see not all objects can be
touched
not all jigs can be seen and we found
that out by
trying to see the sphere that the
klingon has there
we can't see it okay so now we can't use
that
space that which doesn't have shape now
we know what space is
it's that which doesn't have shape it's
the antonym of the word object
so we have object that which has shape
space that which doesn't
uh distance is the space between objects
that's what we call distance that's
separation that gap
okay nothingness there because what is
space that which doesn't have shape so
there is nothing there
nothing in space are synonyms okay
uh and what is location was the set of
distances from one
object to the rest okay i'd like to
synthesize that in a nice little saying
saying
distance is what is what lies between
lengths
okay length and distance are not
synonyms in science in physics okay
length is what an object has which is
continuous matter
from one end to the other of an object
and distance
is what stands between two objects
they're not even remotely the same
concepts
okay so distance and length are not
synonyms
not in science uh in uh mathematical
physics they are
and that's why they run into trouble
because they don't understand the
difference between length and distance
and the reason for that is that they
don't use either one of those concepts
what they what they use in
mathematical physics is distance
traveled
distance traveled what they do they
unroll the measuring tape
because they're interested in measuring
and so they don't have distance or
length in in mathematical physics all
they have is distance traveled
the amount of
um units
that the tape unrolled
okay so if you unroll your tape and you
first have to create a standard
obviously for example the meter
and if you unrolled your tape three
meters well that's the distance traveled
by the
end of your measuring tape
and that's the number that concerns
mathematical physics
it doesn't concern physics at all
physics we have to define everything
qualitatively qualitatively
okay okay another uh
comment made by this gentleman okay
it's good that he drove the the analysis
today the lecture
a circle so we thank them a circle
open this closed disk is two-dimensional
yeah circle is uh two-dimension
no doubt about it it's a plane all
planes are two-dimensional
okay uh except some of the planes that
um
mathematical physics bends into the
third dimension like
riemann triangles and labyski triangles
which i covered a couple
weeks ago in all of the above shapes the
only ones that are objects
is the cube and the sphere and i'm
wondering why because he defined it as
that which you can touch or see
you can't see a an ideal cube you cannot
see an ideal sphere and that's what the
word cube and sphere refer to
uh they referred to or allude to
perfect ideal geometric figures
so neither a cube nor a sphere exists in
real life
again in real life everything's made out
of atoms
and all atoms are
you know any any structure that you
build with atoms
it's going to be irregular when you get
down
deeper you can get to the atom like the
hydrogen atom
and you can say was that a perfect
sphere
well for from our point of view if you
were just to look at it and say well
that's a perfect sphere you know because
we see it
like from a bird's eye if you were at a
man
and you go there and see it up close
well
our atom is uh a bunch of threads that
weave the surface of the electron
known as the electron shell the surface
of the atom
so even at that level if you were at a
man if you had god's eyes and you were
you know that close to the atom the atom
being
a monster and you being smaller than the
atom right
uh you would see that it's not a perfect
sphere either
under that condition so there is no such
thing as a perfect sphere
in the real world out there a perfect
sphere a perfect cube
is only in our imagination and we can
only do it through a projection
you know we we cannot have one out here
okay a perfect sphere out here even even
if you do it lights in other words a
hologram
you won't have a perfect sphere okay
okay and so uh yeah we can't so it's
just uh he
ends up he says just because something
has shaped doesn't mean it's an object
well for that you've got to define the
word object and hopefully you will not
use the
c touch criteria anymore
okay because it's indefensible and here
are very quick
uh reasons why a couple of them this
is back of the napkin kind of thing uh
it involves two objects
whenever you see your touch you're
talking about something that's seeing
something that's touching the object
that you're talking
in question right the target object so
you need two objects to define object
right with c and touch second is
subjective
you know did you really see that spirit
move the
the curtain and yeah you were on drugs
on that day
you were uh drunk whatever you were high
um very subjective objects we can't see
or touch
there are there are objects we can't see
or touch okay we can't see the air
the air is made out of atoms is the air
an object yes or no
does it have shape yes of course has
shaped uh around our planet
it it's a shell it has cell structure
around our planet
but if you want you can blow some air
into a balloon okay and now it has the
shape of
the inside of the balloon which is close
to a sphere you could say
if you're a balloon a spherical right uh
so yeah
air can be shaped to anything you want
and the question is what is the shape
of air no that's the wrong question the
question is
does air have shape
anything made of atoms had better have
shape you can put it in
any container you want if you can yeah
you know if it's you put it in a bottle
it has bottle shape
okay it has shape what is the shape we
don't care
does it change from second to second we
don't care the point is
it has shape okay we get color coded so
that you can see it inside the bottle
inside the balloon or
around the earth and then you'll know
that it does have shape
seeing and touching are verbs and you
always have to define
the word object before you define the
word motion
verb right um because
motion is two or more locations of an
object
all right so uh the object has to move
and if it moves you better have an
object to start out with
you can't have motion without an object
which is what mathematical physics has
they get rid of the object
and they start using points and what are
the points locations so they move
locations
okay so what do we do in
in science well we define the word
object okay and
uh why because
you need what is known as the golden
principle of physics which is you can't
do physics without an object
what would there be to study without an
object what would be happening what if
god
wiped out all the objects in the
universe except himself
unless he's a spirit or whatever okay so
he wipes out all the atoms everything
out there every atom there's nothing
left there
so what is happening assuming you're a
spirit next to
god or god himself what is he staring at
there's nothing in front of him he wiped
out everything
so what is he what is god staring at if
there's nothing in front of his eyes
what is happening
so yes you need objects to do physics
and we separate that or
contrast it with space okay space is
that which doesn't have
shape an object is that which has shape
and objects then we
can point to we point to objects and
name them
so we say chair tree rock house whatever
dog
concepts we define okay so you have to
define what a concept is
uh energy is not an object you have to
define the word energy because it's a
concept
okay and that's why i always say the
definition of the word
object destroys all religions and that's
why this
person is trying to see if he can keep
the c touch
criteria because the definition of
object meaning that which has shaped
destroys
his religion he realizes that so he's
desperately trying to
go into panic mode you know into um
what is called uh he's trying to fix it
you know somehow
because his religion falls there that's
why
okay um what else do i have here
uh yeah okay uh we're gonna move towards
again
finding out uh where we started where is
uh
the tesseract okay we're moving that
direction please have
uh patience we got to go through this
because we got to
find out what a surface is what an
object is
you know these kinds of things we got to
take care of first and show what's wrong
with the definitions
that we currently have for sphere for
um again for surface for location for
all these things
these terms okay okay so where do we
start well we start with the word point
again we need to know what a point
is and this is what it is for
mathematical physics
uh this is the notion that's out there
this is the notion that they
put into what is known as geometry in
which you'll find out that
none of what follows now is a geometric
figure that's the bottom line
and so we have the word point let me put
this up here first
okay so i get this so you can see what
they're referring to with all this
okay give me a second here there he goes
okay
and so we have context there we have the
mathematicians what is a line for them
well it's a bunch of locations
what what they call points or which they
represent pictorially with points okay
with dots
so uh do not confuse the dot with a
location
which is the real notion of the word
point and here you see it a point is a
primitive notion
that models an exact location what is a
primitive notion
it means that it's undefined you know
they don't want to define it because
they can't define it
as a location and then put a dot in
there because the dot belongs to physics
it's two-dimensional
and the location is dimensionless and is
a concept
so it's the point the concept or is the
point the object used to represent it
pictorially that's the question
and it says a point is zero dimension a
zero dimensional mathematical object
well i don't know what a mathematical
object is in physics we only have
objects we don't put any qualifiers in
front of the word object
and there is no object that is zero
dimensional
and that that ends the word point right
there
okay the mathematical machinery uh
used to deal with points can be
surprisingly
slippery no kidding okay well from
uh mathematics uh a bastion of
mathematical physique it says a line is
a straight
one-dimensional figure i don't know
about a one-dimensional figure there's
no such monster
in science or in physics or in the real
world so i don't know what they're
talking about
i don't know if it's straight but for
sure it's not one-dimensional there's no
such object as
one dimension and important just in case
you said well maybe they meant something
else they they clarify says
having no thickness and extending
infinitely in both directions
there is no object that extends
infinitely there is no object that has
no
thickness that is one-dimensional
then it says a line is uniquely
determined by two points
what was a point it's a zero dimensional
mathematical object meaning it's not an
object
and so i don't know how they construct a
one-dimensional
line with zero dimensional points
and what they're really talking about is
locations
and what they're talking about as far as
the line is concerned is an itinerary
and there you see the little turtle
on the lower right okay just walking
along one step at a time one location
at a time they continuous as the notion
of a line is usually left
undefined oh a so-called primitive
object
why do they leave it undefined why don't
they define it so we know what they're
talking about
why don't they say well we're talking
about location and this is the
definition of the word location why
don't they do that
simple one advantage to this approach is
the flexibility it gives no
to users of the geometry no kidding
and then they they put this uh notion
down and at the bottom says
all definitions are ultimately circular
in nature
talk about the fine print okay these
disclaimers
and the wikipedians uh it's a notion
there it's a
article saying a line may be interpreted
as a geodesic
shortest what path they're talking about
a
path they're talking about an itinerary
they're not
talking about a line between points
okay so yeah all of the geometry in its
entirety
so-called geometry with mathematical
physics does
uh none of it is geometry none of it has
to do with
objects uh i mean if they want to do
measurement they want to do calculations
and
angles and all that stuff hey be my
guess knock yourself
out but don't tell me any of what you do
has anything to do with physics
physics deals with the figures
and not one of the uh names used you
know like point line and so on
used in mathematical physics refers to a
figure
it refers only to itineraries locations
which they call points and lines which
only
has the only purpose or the or the
effect is to confuse you
okay because people think they're
talking about geometric figure what
they're talking about is itineraries
and that's what all of relativity
specifically
is founded on itineraries and we're
going to get to that in
the coming weeks but just now i just
want you to
keep that in the back of your mind that
these people are not talking about
geometric figures like when they talk
about space-time
what are they talking about itineraries
they're talking about
motion they're talking about location
but they use
words that sound like geometric figures
points lines
circles etc tesseract right
to to talk about them when
none of those are really geometric
figures
according to mathematical physics
okay um so let's start here
uh just a quick review this is what a
circle is for the purposes
of uh physics okay i'm sorry for for
purposes of mathematical physics a
circle is just
a bunch of locations that's all it is
it's an itinerary
uh it's known as an orbit okay
that's what they're talking about
they're talking about a perfect orbit
there's a center you've got a
string a rope chain whatever
the object is at the end of that rope
and you swing it perfectly
you know conserving the same center all
the time
and so the object has all these
locations and that's what they call
a circle all the locations of that ball
or cube or whatever you got at the end
of your stream so they're talking about
locations they're not talking about a
geometric figure okay
that's what a circle is for the purposes
of mathematical physics
okay so uh what is a semicircle
once again here it is semicircle is
this it's a half a circle so
uh you swing your ball or whatever
you've got like you know in my case here
i got this ball so i swing it around
okay
that's what a circle is but the
semi-circle is just half a swing
and you stop it halfway okay
now you take that and with that you're
going to build a sphere
what is a sphere well you're going to
twirl that itinerary
that geodesic around somehow okay and
here it is you twirl it around
okay and that's what a sphere is just a
twirling
around of a geodesic okay that's what
these people understand by
sphere okay so now that we know that
it's just a bunch of itineraries and
swinging itineraries and so on
let's get down to the tesseract which is
more or less the same thing but not
quite
there is a small difference see what
they did just now
is they moved an itinerary they moved
motion let's make sure we understand
that okay we had
something which they don't identify
because they don't they're not concerned
with some things
they have all these locations that made
up
what the semi-circle okay so we have
locations
we're not talking about an object we're
not talking about a a line which is what
sounds in people's mind they say all
line you know
like a little stick no no it's not a
curved stick it's not a straight stick
not none of that at all what it is is a
bunch of locations
once they map that they're going to
twirl the locations around the set of
locations
and with that they're going to build
this thing they call the sphere
which is a bunch of locations which are
twirling around
that's known as motion and now they're
gonna move the motion
around okay the tesseract
is something even weirder they're gonna
move
time around they're gonna twirl time
around okay and here it is okay so let's
go
slowly with this so that you understand
each point tesseract
also known as a hyper hypercube is a
four
dimensional cube well not really because
look at that this is what the cell says
okay and you look at that no it's got
length with a knight
it's got three dimensions what i see
there and that's what it's called the
test ray
so i don't know what he's talking about
i mean maybe his eyesight fails
uh he can't see the sphere or the cube
that the klingon has
but and i can justify that because he
can't see that far gazillions of miles
away
but this this you should be able to see
you know right there is it's in front of
your eyes it's objective right
what do you see there you see two nested
cubes you could say you know a special
type of cube
you know one that's got uh these
lines connecting the vertices okay
vortex
um but what you see in front of you is
has length width and height so no that
hypercube is not a four-dimensional cube
it's a three-dimensional
nested cube that's what we have in front
of us objectively it's in projection
remember really it's two-dimensional
the one we're seeing but we're
understanding what they're trying to
say here they're saying look you gotta
look at this as a projection okay it's
projection in three-dimensional
uh in a three-dimensional uh background
or
platform okay yeah that's what we have
three dimensional
uh cube uh double cube you get caught
okay so no the
tesseract is not a four dimensional
anything or
q or whatever and it says it is the
extension of the idea of a square
to a four-dimensional location again i
don't know what that means
uh locations are not four-dimensional
okay so
uh locations are dimensionless okay so
we have to define the word location so
we know what it is
no location is a concept and concepts
don't are not made of location
are not made of dimension they don't
have dimensions take any concept you
want
energy mass
time any concept you want
it has no dimensions what is it what
does it have length width and height
those are the three dimensions so i'm
not sure what dimensions
location could have okay it says that a
cube
is the extension of the idea of a square
to a three-dimensional location
again locations don't have
dimensions what an a tesseract really is
okay that that one there is static
and so you say well yeah i know what
that is that's a three-dimensional
nested cube but that's not the notion
they have for a tesseract
tesseract is an expanding 3d cube
that's why time is involved see those uh
vortex there that that unite the corners
of
each one of those cube the one on the
inside and one on the outside
that's time okay that's
motion in the sense of expansion of that
little cube
to the big q that's what what is
represented
there okay so uh tesseract is a concept
that says a cube is expanding
okay that's what it what the word
tesseract stands for
for expansion of a cube and i showed
this the other day
this is my tesseract so that you
understand what we're talking about here
okay
and there it is in in graphic mode
you have a cube that is expanding okay
and what they do with that they build
these two nested cubes which they
represent the small one and the big one
only and they represent the intermediate
ones
with arrows or with lines or whatever
so when you see that cube that's there
on the
far right side okay underneath the red
arrow
well those are two nested cues but those
lines that connect the two
the corners of those two cubes those are
to represent that that little cube is
expanding
okay so it's a like a photograph of
a a movie where they only show the first
frame of the
movie and the last frame of the movie
but the nonsense doesn't stop there
it continues and you can see it on the
left-hand side of the
black region there you can see the cube
is expanding becomes a hypercube
and a super macho hypercube okay so now
they're going to take that super macho
height per cube which is uh a frame that
includes the first and the last frame
they're going to superimpose those two
uh cubes and now they're going to twirl
that
movie that synthesized in one frame
they're going to
throw that one around okay and that's
that's what a uh when you see a
hypercube that's rolling in space that's
the nonsense that the
these folks are representing okay
they're representing
a two nested cubes which is really a
cube that's expanded
you freeze that image with the inner
cube and the outer cube
only not showing the the cubes in
between
right and then they're going to troll
that and what they end up doing is
really
twirling time because what unites those
corners of those two cubes is
those sticks those lines they represent
time it's the expansion of the inner
cube
to fill the outer cube okay
and here you see it i've illustrated
this so you can see what a tesseract
really is
okay first we're gonna expand the cube
here it is okay so you can see the cube
is expanding
okay and the little cube becomes the big
cube and they just represent the little
cube and the big one they just take the
first and last frame of them they say
okay that's a hypercube
well hypercube is is a movie it's that
entire movie synthesized in one frame
of another movie they just take a
snapshot of that superimpose it
do a little collage there a very
selective collage they only take the
first frame and the last frame
okay but again the nonsense doesn't stop
there
here it goes okay here's uh what what
they're gonna do they're gonna troll
that thing now
okay so now they freeze that image
they're gonna twirl time
because remember the lines uh that unite
the inner and outer cube
uh represents the expansion of the
little cube
uh all the way to the big q and then
they're going to twirl this so they're
twirling time
and mathematicians are so used to
twirling time that they
they've lost complete track of what
they're doing
conceptually okay they don't even know
anymore what they're doing
because they're moving time around and
you say but it's time a physical object
can you can you move time can you move
two seconds from here to there
and they go through well now let me
explain there's nothing to explain
they're trying to move time and here
they do they illustrate
they illustrate the motion of time okay
so you say what is time is time a
physical object
and for that you have to go to the
sources okay and here's our one source
that's uh
from space.com okay
space.com okay here we have it an
article that
pretty much synthesizes what time is for
relativist for mathematical physics okay
it says what is time
albert einstein showed that time is an
illusion
oh that's a good definition what is time
that's an illusion
okay thank you i always wanted to know
what time it is others say it's what a
clock measures you know other nonsense
that people say out there
they just copy and paste they don't even
know what they're saying
okay uh it is relative relative
it can be four different uh for it can
be it can vary
for different observers depending on
your speed through space
or maybe through the drug that you took
yeah i wonder what speed they're talking
about here okay what's that got to do
with
what time is with the definition of time
because
the article is called what is time so
finally i wanted to know what the time
is they say well it's an illusion well i
didn't understand that very well that's
not very
uh illuminating i didn't understand that
what do you mean by that well it says it
depends on how fast you go through space
well i still don't have a definition of
what we're talking about what is time
that was the
title of the article okay to einstein
time is the fourth dimension
okay another so it's a what it's an
illusion it's how fast you go through
time is
the fourth dimension we still don't have
a definition i still don't know what
time is okay
it says space is described as a
three-dimensional arena which provides a
traveler with coordinates such as length
width and height
now those are not coordinate those are
known as dimensions
not coordinates showing location
yeah location uh is determined by
coordinates but again those are not
coordinate those are known as dimensions
but people don't understand the
difference between dimensions and
coordinates
coordinates refer to location dimensions
refer to
the uh facing the uh and the pointing of
a
you know the tilt that uh an object has
with respect to the rest of the universe
and it can only point into three
mutually perpendicular
dimensions okay that's different than
the location of the object with respect
to the rest of the matter in the
universe
or with respect to three specific points
uh and again those coordinates have to
be at 90 degrees to each other okay
that's why we
have names for them okay okay time
provides another coordinate
uh no time is not a coordinate time is a
number line
that's what time is it's a number line
not a coordinate
number lines and coordinates have
nothing in common
number lines uh have magnitude and what
they lack is direction
time does not have direction either
there's any number line you can point
the number line any direction you want
because it doesn't have direction you
can make it upwards
sideways to the at 45 degrees doesn't
matter
number lines don't have uh direction
and second number lines are not
perpendicular to anything because they
don't have the
direction okay and uh
on the other hand dimensions have these
those two
uh features uh
they're they have direction and they're
perpendicular
perpendicularity orthogonality they have
those two features
okay and that's why you can't put a
fourth
perpendicular dimension because you
cannot even imagine such a monster
there's only three possible um
orthogonal directions in which
dimensions can point
and or face and you cannot have a fourth
time
perpendicular dimension to that that's
why they never illustrate that they
usually use this
space versus time and they put the three
dimensions as the word space
in one line and against them they put uh
what is it the time like if time had a
direction perpendicular to space
what sense does that make but that's how
mathematical
physics does it okay and it says time
provides another coordinate
uh although conventional direction which
it doesn't
although conventionally it only moves
forward
uh well which way is your forward
because my forward is i think
opposite to your forward so you know if
for you time goes forward for me it goes
forward in that direction for someone
else's
time goes forward in another direction
forward is not a direction
forward is is a reference
in which direction you're you're
pointing
in other words it's it's not a direction
at all there is no such
direction known as forward your forward
is opposite mind
forward and so time and time doesn't go
forward at all
forward it has to do with again if
you're using their terminology
forward has to do with space in which uh
way you're pointing or walking or
whatever
and time has nothing to do with
direction at all
so what they could mean by time moves
forward i have no
idea whatsoever okay so what happens
um because of that they end up
uh with this
i can put this up here put it over here
this is from that article and they say
the following
say uh picture a four dimensional fabric
called space
time uh no i cannot picture that because
space is nothing and time is a concept
so nothing is also a concept for that
matter but i mean
so far we have concepts we don't have an
an object so i cannot
picture it and much less if it's four
dimensional
whatever four dimensional is uh please
draw it and then we'll know what it is
and hopefully it's four dimensional okay
that means that you have four mutually
perpendicular dimensions there okay
i know of three please show us the
fourth one okay that's perpendicular to
the other three
when anything that has mass sits on that
piece of fabric it causes a
dimple or a bending of space time
what the hell are they talking about
bending of two concepts
well here it is here's uh what they
typically show
and you'll see that for both space time
and the tesseract here okay
let me put it over here
and uh so they continue it says
the bending of space-time causes
they're gonna they're gonna cause
something they're gonna cause
objects to move so they're saying if you
bend this concept known as space-time
which they represent with a fishnet
if you bend it just by putting another
concept in it
called mass if you bend it they say that
it causes
objects to move so the cause
the reason you know or cause really
that the mechanism for why objects move
according to these people is that
space-time causes them
triggers them pushes them or pulls them
or whatever
to move that's what they're saying they
move on a curved path
and that curvature of space is what we
know as gravity
okay so this the this is what they teach
these folks at the
monastery i guess okay both the general
and special relativity theories have
been proven with gps satellite
technology
they've proven that they prove that
there's a concept called mass that can
bend
warp okay whatever comes in contact with
a concept called space-time
which then causes objects to move on a
curved path
that's what these people are saying okay
and they say
this has been proven i'm not sure how
they can prove it if you cannot even
imagine
how can you prove something you cannot
even imagine or you cannot illustrate
uh and they continue saying astronauts
are time travelers aha
what is that they return to earth
younger than their identical twins that
remain on the planet
oh man we should travel more often you
know out there in space so we all become
young again you know
the fountain of youth i guess uh general
relativity provides scenarios that could
allow travelers to go
back in time back in time
how do you go back in time i mean you
know i don't know uh
how they do this uh maybe a good shot in
the arm of
some high level drug i don't know how
you can go back in time
so they say it's according to nasa
the equations however might be difficult
or to physically achieve no
kidding yeah i doubt that you can go
back in time and prove it with
um with a physical experiment
you know maybe with equations you can do
that i don't know if you can do that
in the lab build a time tunnel
you know wormhole or whatever okay
um and the same thing happens here okay
and this is known as the hyper sphere
and it's the same thing as the
hypercube or tesseract um
in the sense that what you're seeing is
a
sphere expanding through time and there
you have a static
example and a dynamic example
okay which they use to show how space
time
or the big bang expanded okay
and that's what it is the spell says a
hypersphere has
a three-dimensional surface which curves
into a first
fourth dimensional location again i
don't know what that is
a hypersphere is the four dimensional
analog of
a sphere and yeah what they're doing is
remember what a sphere was
sphere was the twirling of what a bunch
of
locations so we have twirling of the
locations
now those twirling of locations once you
freeze that you
you make a movie with all those little
locations
okay and they're expanding they they
have more distance with respect to the
first
sphere as far as twirling and
you know you take only the first and the
last one i guess you know for the
heisberg sphere
and i don't know what they're united by
but whatever they're united by that
represents time so you have an expansion
of a sphere you know like if you blew a
balloon and you take the first and the
last
uh images you kind of make a collage or
a
superimposed one upon the other and you
say okay this is my hypersphere and then
you're getting i guess you can play ball
with that and you
move time around as well that's what a
hypersphere is that's what
these people talking about
unbelievable okay so um
here is uh follow up on that
which is the icing on the cape as i call
it one pellet says
the tesseract concept blah blah blah
blah blah blah
i thought the first guy started saying
the tesseract is an object
so is asses tesseract an object or a
concept
which is it which all of the above
you know here we have relativity treats
it like an object
okay that's what i say mathematicians
illustrate this object as a two nested
cubes i just showed that and you can see
that if you freeze that image you have
two nested cubes
they put it in motion on top of that so
what they're illustrating is an object
because i can see it's got shape
and that's the definition of an object
that which has shape
and it has shape whether i see it or not
by the way okay
but that's one way of you know showing
that you're saying that you can see it
okay i can't see the one the klingon has
out there but i can see this one
okay that's why we have to distinguish
objects from concepts in physics we have
to know the difference between an
object or a concept because here you
have one guy says the tesseract is a
concept the other guy said no it's an
object
so who's right well the only way we're
going to find out is defining the word
object and the word concept that's how
we're going to find out
he who cannot uh know the difference
between an object and a concept
is not a physicist he's a religionist
he's a mathematical physicist
or a spiritualist or whatever you want
to call them
they're not physicists okay they're not
even scientists
okay and so here are my conclusions math
figures are not
figures mathviz only has
itineraries line circle etc semi-circle
whatever okay
bunch of locations triangles squares
same okay
and also for that matter of spheres okay
all math solids are hollow there's not a
single
mathematical figure which is a
first that is a physical object then
even uh
if if you put something there draw
something and illustrate it
whatever they illustrate they say it's
hollow they're only talking about the
surface about
the membrane you could say that covers a
sphere the membrane that
wraps around a cube or a cone
or a cylinder they're not talking about
a solid they're talking about a hollow
okay tesseract what is it it's a two
it's two nested cube if you just look
at the image okay uh objectively what
you have
in front of you is two nested cubes
that's it but uh
tesseract conceptually what they're
trying to really represent there is an
expanding cube which is a concept okay
because now we're talking about
according to the definition of concept a
word that evokes
or embodies two objects well here you
have two objects essentially okay
because you take the first and the last
frame
it's like if you had two different
objects they're nested one is
superimposed upon the other
that's a concept so the tesseract which
you point to which is two nested cubes
if it's just
what's in front of you objectively
that's an object
but the other one the the notion of an
expanding little cube that turns into a
big cube
that's a concept so these people have to
decide what a tesseract is is it the
first one or the second one
okay and then mathematicians are
spending time when they spin
a tesseract because those
uh sticks that unite the two atoms
those are what those are that those
are that stick represents time
the time it took for the little cube to
become the big one
okay let's get to the questions and
comments
uh for last week really i have to start
with last week because i skipped over
them the other day
okay here's the first comment or
question
they beat me up quite a bit and it's got
to do with observation
and essentially all these people are
saying the same thing they're saying
look
without observation you don't have
anything to explain that's
what all these people are saying here
okay so
i'm not gonna read all of them you can
later on go back if you're interested
and see what
comments these people made essentially
these people are saying
uh you need observation in science
because
otherwise how can you explain something
without observing at first how can you
explain a phenomena
what happened right if you haven't seen
it first
that's their argument that's the bottom
line and here's another
uh comment regarding observation okay
again i'm not going to read it because
too lengthy
but essentially they're questioning
they're saying
oh the bill are you saying that you can
explain something without observing at
first
that's essentially their argument okay
and
again you can read this later on so that
we can move on here
uh another comment on observation
there's at least
four of these that i've got here okay
too lengthy to read
okay you can read it later but again uh
paul says essentially you know
maybe this one i'll read because it's a
little more specific it says
if you want to claim that your
observation or knowledge of the earth
going around the sun had
no hand in formulating your explanation
of gravity
right that your assumption of the earth
and sun's existence as well as the
existence of the ropes
popped out of mere nothingness you are
the dirtiest liar on his entire website
on earth not on the website i'm the
biggest liar on earth
right yeah um
i'll get to that in a minute but i just
want to clarify here that
existence has nothing to do with
observation there is no
provision for the word observation in
existence
things exist uh even if you're dead
okay the moon is going to exist out
there when you die it's going to
continue rolling around the earth okay
unless a
asteroid hits it or whatever okay so no
observation has nothing to do with
existence
okay and i didn't observe the rope
okay so yeah i has nothing to do
with observation and i'll get to that in
a second you claim to hypothesize how
mother nature runs her shop
yet you want to also have all
assumptions about nature totally removed
from nature
arbitrary irrelevant fantasy no matter
how rationally mechanized
is not science yeah
for that you got to define science and
science is rational explanations
and so we're concerned about the
explanations not about
whether you observed it or not we don't
care about your testimony about whether
you observed it or not
and the final comment or question i
guess here on
observation again uh
a guy complains that essentially you
know
i'm removing the word observation and he
says how can you do that
you know you gotta observe before you
can explain so they all say the same
thing
and i'm gonna answer to all of them in
the same way okay so here's my
answer to all of them okay
all the way down at the bottom here if i
can see it find it
there it is
okay this is the answer to all of them
here you have the
scientific definition of the word
science
what is science rational explanations
and there you have the scientific method
to rationally
explain okay you want to explain
something to the crowd
at a conference to your friend whatever
you want to do it scientifically well
then you have to follow the scientific
method which you see in front of you
where
do you see the word observation anywhere
on that page there
do you see the word observation observer
observed
to observe no you don't see observation
at all what is the hypothesis
it's the objects that are going to be
mediating the transactions
the phenomena the definitions
okay and you have the initial scene or
the first frames of the film
what we call the statement of the facts
not the facts
facts only mother nature knows what
actually happened
and she's got that file hidden away from
us all we can do
is present our case okay and people say
well hold it bill
i was there when uh this guy threw the
brick through the window
yeah you were there you saw it
and now you're gonna testify and you're
gonna tell the world you're gonna
tell this chinese man who's on the other
side of the planet you're going to say
i was there i threw how the i saw how
the guy threw the
brick through the window well he's got
to take your word
at face value because he wasn't there
and so he's just relying on your
testimony
and you say i filmed it i got my camera
it was made in hollywood you
you tricked it you know i mean so many
arguments that we could raise
so uh no uh or maybe uh
the guy you film broke the window first
and then someone
put the window back up and another guy
came in uh with a crowbar
the dog jumped through the window and um
and you know that's how the window broke
that's why i see the glass on the floor
now
your film was you know a long time ago
before the window was
fixed again there's so many arguments
that you can raise against that
so again we don't have the exact
uh phenomenon that happened we don't
have the exact thing only mother nature
has it god the devil you know whoever
out there
but they have the the real thing in
their file cabinet we can only
uh we can't say i observed you know the
imagine the prosecutor starting his case
and saying
i observed the defendant
kill his mother-in-law i observed the
defendant robbed the bank
is that how prosecutors begin their
cases when they try to try to convince
the jury
that they testified that they observed
is that is that how an explanation is
started
or could it be that the defense attorney
and the prosecutor they have two
different versions
sometimes not always but many times they
have different versions of how things
happened
okay maybe the prosecutor says this guy
died because he has he was stabbed to
death
and the defense attorney says i know i
ran a test and the guy was poisoned to
death
and then the knife was uh put in his
back
after he was dead or while he was still
dying
from the poison uh so what killed him
well we don't know one guy says it was
the poison the other guy said was a
knife
so we don't know we only have
uh assumptions and we say well let us
assume he died with a knife here's the
weapon
and this is my case the fingerprints
show that this is the
guilty party and the other guy said well
the poison and that came from that class
and has different fingerprints and i
think it came from this other person
so we have two different cases here
based on the assumptions
because we don't know exactly what
happened you could say well let's run a
test
whatever test you run it's going to all
the jury's going to have to rely
on belief no matter what you present i
don't care what you you can stand on
your head the jury is going to
rely on belief it's going to be well do
i believe this guy or do i believe that
guy
that's all it's going to be jury the
jurors always
rely on belief that's why it's only
assumptions you believe the assumption
really
in the case of science it's known as you
concede the assumption
only to understand the theory okay not
to believe it
and so the jury eventually reaches a
verdict meaning their belief
based on the assumptions they give
credence to they say well i'm going to
go with these assumptions in this theory
and the other guy says no i like this
these assumptions over here in these
this theory over here
and that's why you know sometimes these
uh
jurors they spend days inside the box
because they can't reach an agreement on
what actually happened even though you
know
uh only one thing happened in here we
have two different versions
not only of the theory but of the
assumptions okay
another question raised by this indiv by
one individual here
and he says uh those people referring to
the
fermilab mathematicians a video i made
some time ago says
built nuclear reactor and particle
colliders based on that science
what have you actually built what are
your results
okay for that we need to know what
science is again you know what is
science
is science about building reactors and
nuclear weapons and all that good stuff
uh all i can show you is my results
and i think i have better results than
these folks and here it is okay
uh for this you know we have uh
building technology building is not
is equal to technology not equal to
science what is technology technology
inventing developing gadgets by trial
and error
what is science rational explanations
so what this fellow thinks is that
science has to do with building stuff
with
producing physical results in other
words technology
and that's not what science is science
is rational explanations okay
if you don't like that definition no
problem you can come up with your
definition will be glad to tear it to
pieces okay you got to defend it
you can't say well all these people
believe that that's what science is
now that's a statement of authority of
tradition okay
you got to defend the definition of
science
on the stage you know in the ring with
your
sword and shield and then uh
mathematical
physics only has irrational explanations
there's not one
a single rational explanation in all of
mathematical physics
okay why because they never identify the
objects that mediate all these
transactions out there
they do physics without objects they do
calculations they do
equations and then they put in by hand
the assumption which is that everything
is mediated by particles
and the particles aren't particles
either they're equations
condensed as particles and so
these are my results i put the
foundations of physics
okay let me put this over here to the
side um
i also uh the rope hypothesis which is
uh
the thing i'm proposing okay rationally
explains how the
universe works through images okay why
because the hypothesis
is the up is a set of objects that
you're going to use
to explain mother nature's or father
universes or gods or the devil's
invisible intangible world out there
that's the
that's what we're trying to explain how
the universe works how it runs okay
and for that you need objects no matter
what you can't say there's nothing there
that you can't say gravity is not
mediated by an object you can't say
that light is not mediated by an object
you can't say that magnetism is not
mediated by an object
and rope hypothesis identifies the
invisible intangible mediators that
underlie the mechanisms of what light
gravity electricity magnetism and the
workings of the atom
that's what the rope hypothesis does so
those are the achievement those are the
results
and that's what has something to do with
science what these people did
building uh colliders that's not science
that's technology
why did they build the colliders what
are they colliding
uh wave function collapses
waves is that what they're doing
collapsing waves
colliding them okay
fellow says here so we see double taurus
pattern
standing still using feral cells
okay or crt television screens and
magnetism that alone fits the
ludicrous definition of object that
which has shape
i'm not sure why it's ludicrous uh you
just said
it's a definition of object uh correct
uh
if you can see something there but the
question is you don't see
um you say he says he sees double taurus
patterns
a pattern is not an object and we don't
care what the pattern is we need to
identify the physical
object okay so patterns don't stand
still okay because
patterns are concepts that's why we need
to distinguish
concepts from objects researchers
discovered people
form a distinct brainwave pattern when
they are exposed to a magnetic field
that is
equal in strength to earth's magnetic
field
but the pattern emerges only when the
field points
and when the field points and moves in a
certain way
this is uh in the sense of touch
uh well i don't know what what is
touching anything here a way more
comprehensive definition of object
what we can see and touch that is
three-dimensional in a three-dimensional
locational environment
i have no idea what the locational
environment is which can be weighed or
measured
uh yeah i guess same thing as before
you can't measure a three-dimensional
object such as
a ball i'm sorry a sphere
or a cube because those are ideal and
they don't exist so you can't weigh it
you can't weigh a cons
an object that does not exist okay
and a sphere is an object that does not
exist and so is a
square um well square as well but a cube
okay so these are 3d objects that do not
exist they're ideal objects
we can imagine them we can uh make an
image of them in projection on
two-dimensional platform we can do all
that but we cannot
build it okay so no you can't wait you
can't
touch it you can touch the paper but you
can't touch really the uh
the square or the cube okay and
so the definition of object that see and
touch
again invokes a second object the person
doing the scene and touching and so on
which
i just covered a minute ago in both
definitions
magnetism is an object absolutely not
magnetism
is a concept it's a it's a phenomenon
phenomena are not physical objects but
you can draw a phenomenon anytime you
want okay
uh i just need the magnetism drawn i
don't need the iron filings or
any other things that that are indirect
i need the exact
uh image of a magnetic field you can
either draw it yourself
or um you know find uh something on uh
on the internet and just point it to it
with a url next time no problem
you know we'll find out what it is so uh
here it is
c touch okay i'll put it over here
uh these are the problems with the c
touch criteria
can't see touch klingon's magnetic field
two gazillions of
light years away okay we can't see or
touch that so does that mean his
uh cube or his sphere is not a physical
object
can't see or touch the air can't see the
air okay
which is made of atoms and you can see
the
atoms that make your table in other you
can see the table
which is made of atoms you can't see the
air which is also made of
atoms uh so it's because you can't see
it it's not an object
even though both are made of atoms okay
so yeah you got a problem there with
your definition uh
you can't see a circle i'm sorry you can
see a circle
uh you can't touch it you touch the
paper you touch the screen but you can't
see this
you can see the circle but you can't
touch it okay so does that mean that
because
you can see it i mean here you have only
half
half your definition you can see it but
you can't touch it
the other one you can touch the air you
can touch you can't see it uh
what criteria should we use i mean
should it should be an
or or an and for c and touch
and uh the c touch uh criteria is
subjective okay did you really see the
spirit when you were high
okay or drunk if you didn't see her
touch
uh your mama okay today does th she stop
being an object
i mean maybe you're in california and
she's in new york
you didn't see her you didn't touch her
does she become an object only when you
can see or touch her
does she stop being an object as soon as
you can't see her touch it
she calls you on the phone says son can
you see her touch me
no that means i'm not an object that's
true you
you'll be an object as soon as i can see
her touch you again
so what is she she turned into a concept
or i mean
what's going on here spirit does she
seems to exist which is another you know
c
touch criteria for exist as well so
i put down there the only purpose of the
c touch criteria
of ordinary speech is to stealthily
introduce technology
into science because
what are we going to do in the lab we're
going to run an experiment for what to
develop technology
is that science no science is explaining
mechanisms as it relates to physics okay
it's explaining mechanisms we need to
know how this universe works then we're
done
with science once we figure out how this
universe there is
no more physics one branch of science
what continues is philosophy which is
explaining
uh causes i'm sorry purposes
and reasons why someone did something
okay and again just in case
rub it in okay here's the klingon can
you see or touch this square
his cube or his sphere the answer is i
think no
he's one gazillion light years away
unless you have superhuman um
eyesight then no you can't see any of
that
and does that render his
sphere and his cube as non-objects
no those are objects they are objects
that do not
exist they don't have location
okay a couple more issues here
first one uh follows that i think it's
the same guy he says
when we use vortex coils we are putting
magnets into motion with what
frequencies it's just that simple
well i don't know what uh i don't want
to put words in his mouth but i drew
this freak that he's talking about
uh and he's pushing a magnet is that
what uh
what he's referring to when he says this
freaky frequency whatever
i mean what does the frequency look like
he says that
the frequency is causing the magnet to
move
now i can imagine a dog pushing a magnet
with his nose i can
kick it with my toe there's so many ways
to move
an object but the only way i can move an
object is by
having it come in contact with another
object
otherwise you know you're introducing
spirits and this guy says he does it
with something he calls
frequency a freaky freaky frequency okay
and yeah if the freak is what's pushing
a magnet i drew that one there but i
mean if he's got a
yeah i don't again i don't want to put
words in his mouth if he's got another
freak out there that does
that pushes magnets he should draw it he
should show us what he's talking about
when he says
that a freak pushes magnets
okay uh one file says
i like this one uh he says
boring us to death with your two-hour
monotones
there's a quick solution and i
i just don't know why you didn't think
about it you know you just
can tune off after the first two minutes
if you want
i mean didn't you think about that why
did you wait two hours
how did you know it was two hours did
you just look at the
time on the video and uh
final issue foul says
says bill why don't you
make a video about satanism
well yeah i am satan okay
i didn't put my three sixes there in my
forehead
okay i'm also god okay
when i dress up as god i remove this
three six it's like now i'm i'm god
right now okay
i'm the author of a book called the
bible and i hope you've read it for your
own sake i mean when you get up there to
the bernie gates
uh i'll be talking to you okay and so
what i wrote in the bible and you
i want you to see that here's proof that
i'm both god in the devil you know
whenever
it suits my fancy okay and again the
anger of the lord
me yours truly okay was kindled against
israel and he i
moved david against them to say go
number israel and judah
and you'll find that in book two of
samuel right
and it's at 24 1. okay
and then in another book uh chronicles 1
21 1
i say something similar i hope you
caught this i hope you all read this
not read it today okay and satan yours
truly
mom okay stood up against israel and
provoked
david to number israel
so i put proof in the book that i'm both
god and the double now you can you know
you can call me jehovah if you want you
can call me
satan lucifer or you can just call me
bill
and i'll see you on sunday we'll see you
then
bye